[Musique]
comme avec une jolie comme loin qu'une
seule histoire vers paris voilà
bonjour la liste rodez bonjour et merci
d'avoir accepté cet entretien vous êtes
professeur d'histoire géographie dans un
collège de seine-saint-denis
et puis vous êtes également le directeur
de l'observatoire de l'éducation au sein
de la fondation jean jaurès qui vient de
publier une note que vous avez co écrite
avec salomé berlioux une détaillé
intitulé apprendre et enseigner par
temps de crise sanitaire regards croisés
ville campagne on va y revenir mais
d'abord racontez nous votre expérience
d'enseignant de ces deux mois
d'enseignement à distance comment s'est
déroulé s'est mise en place l'école à la
maison avec vos élèves pour dire la
vérité elle s'est mise en place tant
bien que mal tant bien que mal parce que
d'abord même si on pouvait s'attendre à
une fermeture des écoles après que
l'italien a fermé les siennes le 5 le 5
mars de mémoire
on a quand même été pris un petit peu
par la surprise
il a fallu s'organiser très vite or
effectivement ce qu'on a vu très vite ce
qu'on savait déjà c'est que les
plateformes numériques qui servent
d'interface de communication entre les
familles et les établissements scolaires
et bien ne sont pas toujours très
fréquenté et il ya des jeux parfois des
problèmes de code des problèmes de
connexion tout le monde n'est pas
équipée non plus à la maison pour
pouvoir correctement se connecter donc
il a fallu et ça a été la première chose
garder le contact avec les élèves et
pour garder contact avec les élèves bien
je crois que les profs en tout cas dans
mon établissement mais je ne sais que je
sais par ailleurs que ça s'est passé un
peu de la même manière tout le monde
s'est un petit peu débrouiller pour
essayer de garder le contact avec les
mêmes c'est à dire qu'on s'est un petit
peu ah si il faut le dire quand même sur
le verger donc le règlement de la
protection sur la protection des données
et on a constitué des listes whatsapp
des listes des mets liste des groupes
télégramme et c'est parce qu'elle est
les enseignants n'ont pas le droit
d'accéder aux données personnelles
en coordonnées précises bien sûr que non
c'est formellement interdit sauf que là
il fallait absolument garder contact
avec les élèves or comme je voulais
comme je vous le dis les interfaces ne
sont pas toujours
fréquenté le réflexe n'est pas
nécessairement acquis ni par les parents
ni par les élèves donc il a fallu
bricoler il a fallu bricoler
personnellement j'ai passé deux ou trois
jours à essayer de récupérer des numéros
de téléphone à droite à gauche et a
constitué mais mais mais l'hist ministre
mais l'histoire de sap les gros poids de
sape pour pouvoir travailler voilà et on
a commencé à travailler et on a commencé
à travailler avec ce que nous n'avions
jamais fait en réalité c'est à dire
faire des cours en visioconférence alors
racontez nous comment ça s'est passé est
ce que vous avez réussi à transmettre
est-ce que vous avez enseigné est ce
qu'il ya des actes il y d'apprentissage
qui ont été faits au cours de cette
période je l'espère et nous le verrons
moment du des confirmands parce qu'on va
revenir là dessus évidemment on va
laisser les élèves avec ce qu'on a fait
pendant le des compliments on reviendra
là-dessus et c'est à ce moment là que je
pourrais éventuellement vous dire s'il
ya eu des acquis mais on a innové on a
innové il a fallu faire des cours à
distance il a fallu préparer des cours
autrement parce que faire des cours en
visio ce n'est pas la même chose que de
faire des cours en présentiel les élèves
ne branche pas leur caméra donc moi je
ne sais pas s'ils comprennent ils
comprennent pas donc à voilà il faut
c'est très compliqué donc moi ce que
j'ai fait c'est que j'ai donné un
travail préparatoire systématique avant
chaque courant visioconférence et puis
les travaille dessus ce qui fait que
voilà c'est de voir deux fois les choses
et insisté sur les sur les choses après
il ya une réalité aussi
ce n'est pas parce que vous dites que
vous êtes un vilain cours en
visioconférence que tous les élèves sont
là loin de là loin de là puisque j'ai
plusieurs classes mais j'ai une classe
par exemple qui suit très régulièrement
avec 15 15 à 16 élèves présents sur 22
c'est un collège qui est classé en zone
d'éducation en réseau d'éducation
prioritaire avant qu'on limite à 23 par
classe quinze à seize présent
systématiquement à chaque cours et puis
j'ai une autre classe de c'est beaucoup
plus compliqué où j'ai eu par exemple
lundi dernier un cours à six élèves les
voilà ça veut dire qu'il me manquait les
trois quarts pratiquement les trois
quarts des élèves trois quarts des
lèvres avec qui vous avez et perdu
complètement le contact ou partiellement
non partiellement c'est à dire que dans
ces classes en général j'ai nous ranger
est l'établissement qui a cherché par
l'intermédiaire de ce qu'on appelle la
vie scolaire les cpe puis par les chefs
d'établissement d'entrer en contact avec
les familles et bien de certaines
familles n'ont pas répondu ou les élèves
ne répond pas là on peut estimer à un
quart voire peut-être 30 % des élèves
qui ont décroché qui ont qui le plus
signe de vie ou alors qu'ils ne rendent
aucun devoir et qui ont complètement
scolairement décrocher c'est énorme
comme si fera je me permets de souligner
vous l'expliquez comment alors jeune
explique d'abord parce qu'on appelle la
fracture numérique évidemment j'ai des
élèves qui n'ont de qui n'ont pas de
connexion qui n'ont pas de matériel le
collège a prêté du matériel mais les
connexions ne sont pas là certains de
mes élèves suivent sur un téléphone
portable le téléphone portable c'est
peut-être celui de papa ou de maman qui
peut en avoir besoin le manque
d'équipements aussi parce que quand on a
un c'est l'ordinateur et qu'on a trois
ou quatre frères et soeurs qui sont eux
aussi scolarisés et bien il faut se
partager l'ordinateur c'est très
compliqué tout cela ça c'est la première
chose la deuxième chose c'est qu'il faut
savoir aussi que mes élèves ce sont les
enfants des gens qui sont en première
ligne aujourd'hui et qui assure la
logistique nous permettant à nous d'être
confiné ce sont les gens qui travaillent
dans les supermarchés dans la logistique
dans le transport et ces gens se lèvent
très tôt le matin et vont travailler
toute la journée ils laissent leurs
enfants seuls ce qui est logique et bien
ses enfants la journée ils sont livrés à
eux-mêmes et vous faire écouter edouard
philippe il a eu une expression très
forte au sénat cinq mois de décrochage
scolaire pour des milliers de jeunes des
dizaines de milliers de jeunes
c'est probablement une bombe à
retardement
le premier minitre un coût évidemment
les deux mois de vacances dans ces cinq
mois ce que vous êtes d'accord oui
l'expression est très forte et je crois
que le premier train raison de tirer le
signal d'alarmé parce que
d'aucuns vous diront trois mois sans
apprentissage ce n'est pas grave
dans l'absolu ce n'est pas grave on est
d'accord quoique ça dépend de pire on
parle effectivement si on parle des
élèves qui ont leurs parents à la maison
avec qui prennent le petit déjeuner le
matin est acquis avec qui il discute
culture et histoire effectivement il n'y
aura pas de problème mais pour mes
élèves qui ont déjà un capital culturel
qui n'est pas celui des élèves de
centre-ville où des beaux quartiers
c'est trois mois ce sens et sans école
ce sera un handicap supplémentaire dont
ce n'est pas anodin et au delà de cela
c'est oublier que l'école notamment dans
ces quartiers populaires des grandes
agglomérations
ce n'est pas seulement le lieu de
l'apprentissage c'est aussi le lieu
d'une sociabilité cellule c'est un vieux
repères qui donne des caps qui donne des
limites dont nos élèves ont absolument
besoin et c'est aussi un lieu
d'ouverture sur le monde d'ouverture à
d'autres façons d'envisager de voir le
monde quand on en vit dans des
situations compliquées dans des familles
qui sont parfois très fermé et bien
l'école c'est un lieu de respiration et
ça c'est très important
on vous sent très engagé personnellement
sur cette question du décrochage presque
en colère est ce que vous êtes un
fervent partisan pour ses élèves dans
votre département et pour tous les
élèves après tout de la réouverture des
écoles alors donc dans l'absolu
évidemment il faut que les conditions
sanitaires soient absolument respecter
c'est la sécurité de tous est la
première des priorités mais oui je suis
un fervent partisan de la reprise de
l'école parce que encore une fois ne
pensez l'école qu'en termes
d'apprentissage
et ne penser la difficulté des familles
qu'en termes dette financière ça ne
suffit pas ce n'est pas la question en
réalité la question c'est la question de
l'insertion sociale dans des règles qui
font société et c'est cela que nous
sommes en train de perdre je discutais
la semaine dernière avec des éducateurs
éducatrices qui suivent quelques-uns de
mes élèves et l'éducatrice me disait
avec grand une véritable émotion dans la
voix qui m'a beaucoup touché nous sommes
en train de perdre 10 elle des dizaines
de gamins c'est une catastrophe alors
que pensez vous de tous vos collègues
enseignants qui explique bien souvent
pas tous qu'il n'est pas possible de
rouvrir les écoles l'urgence sanitaire
et la protection sanitaire c'est
extrêmement important mais il ya une
urgence il ya une urgence sociale et je
crois que
je crois que nous devons peut-être
prendre exemple sur les soignants qui ne
se ne se pose pas la question de savoir
si ils doivent aller travailler ou pas
c'est une question d'urgence sanitaire
eh bien je crois que pour nous notamment
dans les territoires des 2 c de c2c de
ses banlieues des grandes agglomérations
il ya une urgence sa venue social je
voudrais qu'on parle également des
campagnes et des jeunes ruraux un voulé
d'évoquer tout à l'heure on dit beaucoup
que le confinement accélère les
inégalités la fracture numérique elle
pèse aussi lourdement pour ses élèves
ses étudiants qui vivent dans des zones
enclavées quand on est en zone en zone
rurale en zone de montagne moyenne
montagne par exemple il ya des zones qui
sont blanches et qui ne n'ont pas de
connexion internet c'est devient très
compliqué pour l'enseignement à distance
même pour recevoir aujourd'hui les les
les devoirs et les cours puisque tout
est envoyé par internet quand ça
fonctionne mal c'est très compliqué donc
il ya d'abord cette fracture numérique
qui est quand même très importante il ya
ce sentiment d'isolement aussi qui a été
relatée n'en parle dans l'étude que nous
avons fait avec avec salomé berio et
jérémy paitier que vous avez des sites
et 7 ce sentiment d'isolement de
solitude qui est très fort dans les
milieux dans les milieux ruraux et puis
il y a aussi ses difficultés liées
notamment à l'orientation et
l'orientation future parce que si dans
les grandes agglomérations vous avez
l'offre d'orientation qui n'est pas loin
grâce aux transports en commun même si
les transports en commun je comprends
que ça va être compliqué mais a
néanmoins l'offre l'offre et y est ici
elle est présente dans les territoires
ruraux l'offre peut-être très lointaine
donc en fonction justement de cette
réalité d'un beaucoup d'élèves sont en
train de de renoncer à cette à leur
orientation quitte à redoubler ou quitte
à faire une orientation par défaut autre
sujet le baccalauréat le bac qui n'aura
donc pas lieu pour la génération 2020
c'est le contrôle continu un don qui
tiendra lieu d'évaluation pour les
élèves de terminale et c'est une
première parce que même en mai 68 alors
que les lycées étaient bloqués il y a eu
un oral ça va peser sur ce diplôme si
symbolique et si décrié aussi par la
suite à votre avis alors sur l'oral
l'oral du bac de français mais c'est
l'oral effectivement un terminal qui est
qui est supprimé alors est-ce que ça
aura un impact
écoutez je ne le crois pas tout
simplement parce que il faut savoir
d'abord en 1968 le nombre de le taux de
bacheliers étaient beaucoup beaucoup
plus faible qu'aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
le bac qu'ils soient professionnels
général ou technologique
on connaît les chiffres on est à plus de
plus de 85% donc le bac aujourd'hui et
c'est pour ça que j'ai vu cette réforme
menée par le ministre jean michel
blanquer il a été un petit peu
déconsidérer il est un petit peu
dévalorisés donc je ne suis pas sûr que
le fait que ce bac cette année ne soit
pas soumis à un examen final le change
le regard que nous avions globalement
sur le baccalauréat et les parents les
parents qui ont dû faire de la
continuité pédagogique et parfois qu'ils
ont réalisés au four la difficulté de la
tâche de l'enseignant vous en sortez
grandi à leurs yeux vous pensez je
l'espère je l'espère parce que ce que
nous avons pu ce que j'ai pu voir ce que
j'ai pu constater c'est le fort
engagement d'une manière générale du
corps enseignant dans cette continuité
pédagogique avec les moyens qui étaient
les siens avec les déperditions que dont
nous avons parlé c'est une évidence mais
les professeurs se bat même encore
aujourd'hui pour rattraper les élèves
qui ont tendance à lâcher donc je vois
cet engagement je vois aussi quand
fonction des milieux on n'a pas
forcément la même attitude je vois
combien les parents sont reconnaissants
seine-saint-denis du travail fourni par
les enseignants et puis je peux voir
aussi dans certains quartiers parisiens
par exemple des associations de parents
d'élèves qui se plaignent que la prof
machin ou le le prof bidule n'a pas n'a
pas donné de voir toutes les semaines et
c'est sans tenir compte de la réalité du
confinement c'est à dire que les
enseignants ils ont parfois aussi des
enfants des enfants en bas âge zinc dont
ils doivent s'occuper qu'est-ce qu'il
faudra garder de toute cette expérience
ou surtout ne pas conserver moi je crois
que la grande leçon c'est
c'est de travailler de faire travailler
de faire réfléchir sur justement les
urgences scène d'urgence sanitaire et la
situation d'urgence sanitaire c'est à
dire la situation de confinement rien ne
nous dit que dans les 20 ans qui
viennent nous ne revivrons pas une
expérience telle que celle ci donc nous
avons dans les établissements scolaires
des protocoles pour
l'instant 10 des protocoles pour les
risques d'attentats depuis peu un je
crois qu'il faut mettre en place des
protocoles d'urgence lié à l'urgence
sanitaire et ça veut dire par exemple
avoir connaissance de l'équipement de
chaque famille du lien de chaque famille
avec le numérique et que les
établissements soient équipés pour venir
en aide à ceux qui n'ont pas les moyens
de s'équiper ont finalement d'un mot
rien ne remplace le contact physique
entre l'enseignant et l'élève je crois
que cette période de l'école l'école en
confinement l'école à la maison
a mis un terme à la discussion sur les
bienfaits du numérique dans le
pédagogique
voilà je crois que rien ne vaut la
présence la présence et le lien physique
que l'on vu qu'on a dans les classes
parce que c'est là que se construit les
changes pédagogique c'est là que te
construis l'enseignement
le numérique c'est un plus mais ça ne
peut être qu'un plus merci infiniment
merci ziani ce travers
[Musique]